was becoming pam more difficult than
becoming judy garland or or less
intimidating i don't know which one i
feel like it would be intimidating play
judy garland wow that's you nailed it
thank you but i just mean that would be
intimidating
no i just uh i try to i try to remove
myself from uh from uh the reality of it
which is that you're creating something
that you know folks are going to see and
i just kind of get
go uh
yeah that's it just dive into it and and
do the work so i just get really
involved in the work and it becomes
about that so i don't think about
anything else i'm just curious
from that perspective yeah so um but
this was um it was hotter it was hotter
i was not it was hot no it was no
there's a lot of comedy involved because
you got to laugh your way through stuff
like that you know so
but i've never worked with full
prosthetics like that before and it's a
skill that i didn't know that i did not
have
that i was not excited i did not know it
was fun to learn you know but it's fun
on the first day when you go oh wait
yeah that's okay i can't i'm smiling but
you can't tell
oh my god like acting in that such a
hard thing oh my gosh i never thought
about that how to move these things and
you have to yeah but aryan he's a genius
and yeah yeah he's really good it's
incredible i tell i call my glam squad
harry potter i do not look like this
i was like you will see me in target be
like wait what
[Music]
you